hey it's Kennedy for recent TV I'm in
front of the IRS building where there is
a flash protest put on by the Tea Party
Patriots let's go see what it's all
about
the rally's already started yeah no but
you're you're a little late on the
strange man I'm trying to catch up the
IRS has targeted individual people based
on their religious views their political
views and their views on many issues
we're not going away we're going to be
here stronger than ever we're not
backing down and we're never giving up
is there interrupting cow
do you rent in your suit or do you Onan
only I like your getup where'd you get
that sweatshirt Target cute did you make
it or did you have someone fashioned it
for you it was actually made for a
Discovery Channel TV on Washington TV
movie
there are several department of homeland
security officers behind me I'm assuming
they are gauging the threat level to see
if these tea party protesters are
actually going to try and storm the IRS
building this is to me the same thing
that KGB was doing in the Soviet Union
I'm Ukrainian origin you know a little
something about the old country yes
beauty of our country is that we can
disagree and when we disagree then we
are able to do that peacefully and you
can't use the IRS to silence citizens
it's like sex in Pat Benatar said stop
using sex as a weapon
okay what's the craziest deduction
you've ever put on your attacker
well since I came before the time of
taxes I don't file taxes there's audit
insurance insurance you can actually pay
for that you can pay for it at turbo tax
soon as you click submit and innovative
actually if you want to you know hey in
case some clown in this building doesn't
like you or find your name associated
with like I don't know a tea party group
we need a thorough investigation to find
out who all was involved and those who
are involved need to be held accountable
thank you very much thank you
you